vous le croyez mort depuis des dizaines
d'années mais depuis tout ce temps il
était dans son bunker au fin fond de la
russie
on joue sur wii car ils sont beaucoup
d'efforts de squeeze messieurs dames les
accueillir le grand l'unique salut
bonjour je suis le petit père des
peuples et gemalto va de travers comme
le président français
aujourd'hui je suis de retour pour
terminer une guerre qui ne s'est jamais
terminée bon voilà c'est terminé mais on
fait genre les amis aujourd'hui on est
pardon compatriotes aujourd'hui nous
sommes sûrs qu'à moderne challenge un
jeu dans lequel nous allons revivre la
guerre froide place thomas près du
bouton pour faire toi tes ennemis prend
la pipe et fumât pour retirer ton stress
presse pay for middle button to drop a
dit m d'accord fait attention à ce que
l'horloge n'atteignent pas midi sinon tu
as perdu d'accord ok donc faut juste que
je vais de mon doigt dessus du bouton et
j'ai gagné voilà c'était staline a très
vite
bon bah ça les ressorts de gagner une
guerre l'a dit comme ça raccrocher au
nez ou ne pas répondre à un appel fait
baisser l'intégrité de l'état des coraux
fume la pipe on met la pression
oh [ __ ] donc il faut que je ok faut
que je mette la tomate où je mette la
normale enfin le rail ok j'ai compris ce
qu'on peut fumer la pipe en même temps
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle donc on
peut se déstresser tout en étant
immédiatement stressé par les mecs au
téléphone sans fil
je peux occuper dans le nez tranquille
c'est staline ans il fume la pipe comme
personne les alliages
voilà c'est comme ça que les états unis
ont envoyé une bombe nucléaire sur
hiroshima sans faire exprès on fume on
met la pression on fume on met la
pression avec nos excellents en v3 au
téléphone on se muscle un peu le bras
parce qu'on est staline et qu'il faut
pas déconner on tape dans le téléphone
parce que ma combi de fil nous casse les
couilles
mais nantes et xiamen mexes a buté il
m'appelle plus que ma mère m'en sers et
commun d'une guerre qui va déconner aux
questions il a terminé ça dégage [ __ ]
on est passé à peu de la chaîne bombe
nucléaire à cause d'un téléphone qui
tombent quand même ça gratte beaucoup à
5-4 vraiment au caire face action on a
un grand chef la lampe est déverrouillé
quand elle se met à clignoter ça te
stresse donc il faut que tu la frappe
pour quelques clients de plus finalement
comme n'importe quel en piqué ok c'est
parti ça clignote
tiens on est bien on est bien on est
bien faisait rentrer la peep le coup le
bouton la peep fm [ __ ] je comprends
pas quand il fut des fois il faut pas
fumer m'énerve des fois pendant 5
secondes il dit avoir été la pipe sont
pour la santé quand même pas déconner tu
fumes ça te des stress merci à tous
j'étais pas vous abonner à ma chaîne
youtube staline gaming
amputé georges delfosse être la guerre
entre la lampe le téléphone le bouton
mon gars et cette musique qui me stresse
énormément
ok japon [ __ ] mais accélère et qui se
raconte au téléphone le gard ok toujours
faire attention téléphone serait pièce
un bain très gros piège effet après j'ai
le stress ok moi si je met à trembler
comme staline sauf que moi j'ai répondu
stressé as tu arrêtes ça c'est gratuit
au bout de mes quelques tricks
incroyable merci à tous ok continues tu
va débloquer à votre cas boire un petit
verre de vodka sérieux at-on de stress
appuyez sur la cloche pour le commander
sommes à ça me plaît ça alors ça mon
pote autant dire qu'on va payer
n'importe bla on la boit et on la voit
sous car il fallait truc style et comme
ça se termine un fait le numérique va
devenir des 1 x staline téléphonique ou
pas et ouais bah il faut aussi des
villages talent et noah au nom d'un
prétendu funéraire votre coeur l'ennemi
est fort est confirmée nous avons des
outils pour miner cette confiance oh
[ __ ] il ya le téléphone ya tout donc
la peep le doigt tordu le début d'un
mauvais film porno et voilà je passe
encore pour affaires verts allaient
répondre au téléphone la seule chose oui
allô parle à ma pipe tu veux tirer at le
téléphone de comment ça se passe à
talons oui je suis là je suis lâche le
hockey c'est bon là lors la vodka la
techno chic où plongent me mêler les
pinceaux au japon par les quotas mais le
mec qui m'appelle toutes les secondes
j'ai pas tourné pour nous au dessus du
bouton ok c'est bon attends ça a sonné à
brême que je raccroche le guen et dans
le futur c'est pas grave allez on se
calme non alors on va perdre la guerre
tu que tu m'appeler fils de [ __ ] voilà
ce que j'aurais dit c'est le compléter
le pistolet les verrouiller quoi ça
augmente intégrité de l'état quand tu
arrives à utiliser et city arrive pas ça
l'a réduit quand j'arrive à utile
commence à réussir à utiliser
on va pas tuer des gens quand même c'est
quoi cette histoire de gannat tan tan
tan tan tan tan tan la non mais pour qui
je fasse
on efface l'épreuve
on efface tout de suite l'épreuve adam
et on tue des gens ou tuer des gens
parce qu'on est resté mon gars je serai
pas trop bien contenu le mec qui arrête
pas de nous appeler au [ __ ] choix
entre un navet je me fais des idées à
battants attendre la 48e le serveur web
oui je fais ça là à temps mais doublée
par la sublime halle c'est un sketch
mais [ __ ]
abla plus serveurs non ça c'est fait
voilà voilà comment gars d'une guerre je
suis staline
non mais la mecque wassim est le
téléphone le gun l'avocate je vais
mourir tamek j'ai trop de trucs à faire
à la seconde je vois tu es un gars
arrêtez une lampe répondent au téléphone
à l'afp hutin de mer qui m'appelle en
pleine guerre c'est bon pas les gages à
bas la sams m comme j'ai eu l'impression
que ma moustache et l'a dit j'arrête
j'arrête
oh mon dieu ils ont mis la totale quoi
la vodka le téléphone le bouton on est
mort on fume le bouton on fume le mouton
s'allumèrent ta gueule ouais cela alors
aux mondiaux mais qu'est-ce qu'on gère
non à genève ri sont tellement judas qui
était une fausse manipulation ça arrive
les répercussions sont pas si grave que
ça prend un peu puis je leur pose
j'apprends avec cette main mais un petit
coup à la longue c'est gratuit ça fait
toujours plaisir ça simplement plaisir
ce niveau est super lot événements qui
allaient mac a buté pour passer le temps
la vodka situation de crise là je peux
jamais l'avoir su le alors fait une
famille très vite fait vite mon bras se
lèvent tout seul agente en plus je passe
sous un tunnel
ok c'est bon ça dégage au bon dieu or la
pression sur l'allée durer une éternité
fly and locked flight depuis quand il ya
des mouches de mon bureau mais je fais
pas une femme de ménage tous les jours
pour qu'ils aient des mouches dans mon
bureau alors on a aussi des brouilles et
la peinture
voilà mais elle elle sert juste à rien
alors je sais pas bien la mouche homme
saoul et je sens que ça va me saouler je
suis pas d'humeur suis pas d'humeur
casse toi ô la placerait juste à
peut-être bouton pour chasser une fausse
manip qui gagent tâche de fond est
exécuté sur la place publique [ __ ]
mouche dégage et un douzième jour mon
dieu qu'est-ce qu'on va gagner cette
guerre un jour je commence à faiblir au
bordel ils ont tout mis
ça m'a fait du bien je veux pas un bon
rythme je fais un beau italienne voit
sur ces d'un filtre elle aussi en bresse
et les américains ils ont réussi à
transformer des humains en mouche et les
envoyer pour mentionner [ __ ] l'enculé
je le savais dégage d'accord donc la
mode vient de voler puis je pas si vous
avez vu ce calme scandale heures
alors c'est comme tu m'appelle pour me
dire qu'on a gagné la guerre on a tous
voila pu marquer pendant ta gueule
[ __ ] mais ils n'arrêtent jamais c'est
la septième fois tu vas tu es cherradi
doit finir par nous cramer a atteint les
niveaux sont de plus en plus long je
transpire de plus en plus ça me gratte
de plus en plus plus rien de beau [ __ ]
j'y arrive même plus à viser avec une
arme alors sa spécialité hockey a
continué en échouant à ça c'est le
réveil qui m'indique que ma journée est
terminée [ __ ] bah oui la gare attendra
demain on oculaire c'était le petit père
des peuples
là je deviens le petit client départ des
peuples a l'air très vite tallinn est en
cdi 35 heures il venait terminer sa
journée
il a alors se bourrer la gueule au bar
du coin sans penser à la guerre comment
tout cela va-t-il se terminer
la mouche va-t-elle s'en aller le fdp
canapé va-t-il trouver dans d'atroces
souffrances
ikea vont-ils lui envoyer une langue qui
fonctionne correctement le serveur
amènera-t-il plus d'un shooter à la fois
tant de questions restent sans réponses
a très vite